8 news now breaking news alert
we begin with breaking news on this
monday afternoon metro police
investigating a homicide near nellis and
las vegas boulevard let's get out right
now to bianca holman she is standing by
with the very latest bianca
good afternoon heather so this situation
happened just before 10 a.m that's when
police were called out here to nellis
and las vegas boulevard you can see it
happened in this apartment complex
that's right down the street from nellis
air force base and around the corner
from an elementary school parts of the
apartment complex are still blocked off
as police investigate this homicide now
police were called to the nellis gardens
apartment this morning the shot spotter
notification went off and a 911 call was
made the caller told the operator they
believe it was a domestic argument
between a man and a woman in the complex
parking lot when police arrived they
found a black woman in her late 20's
with a gunshot wound she was taken to
the hospital where she later died the
man who police believe is the suspect is
in custody they are questioning him and
these are preliminary details as more
develops we'll keep you updated online
and police are asking if you know
anything about this situation if you
were here this morning at the nellis
garden apartment complex to go ahead and
call police where you can remain
anonymous bianca holman live local now